tire and quotas there's quotas that
companies have where they say we need to
again if you're cutting me off again
yeah yes you need to have a certain
amount of females in certain roles why
because there's not enough female
representation because they don't want
to do it because women don't want to
have positions of power no they don't
you know what I really wish you luck
with the rest of your women I really
hope that when you yourself because it's
Shame Shame and saw guilt and the need
to be right it's not shame it's shame
because right now you're trying to
you're right hold on right now right now
right now you are you you are ultimate I
really hope that you do some more
research okay okay okay you guys are
really doing it same same insult guilt
need to be right same for the camera I
will okay bye